but you and sam like those the
one-liners i mean
it's such a rarity in film that you have
these these quotable
phrases that you you came up with these
one-word kind of things
so when you said groot groovy or you
said
chainsaw or you said these little things
did that just start and then it just
goes we got to continue that did you
find that it wasn't in the script was it
um sam wanted groovy for evil dead too
uh ash puts a chainsaw rig together
cuts his his shotgun in half flips it
puts it in the holster and he tracks it
and
he says i wanted a word that by in 1986
was very out of it this is the reagan
era
you know and no one used groovy in 1986
at least not to not to my knowledge and
sam's like i want you to say
groovy and then so he sam would come up
with a lot of this stuff
um and either pitch it
on the day like just before like our
army of darkness
i'm supposed to kiss m beth davids and
let her hair down and
kiss her and we can't find sam anywhere
on set their abs are trying to find him
and they find him giggling over in the
in a corner
like okay what's that all about and he
comes over to me he goes i know what
you're gonna say
i know what you're gonna say i go i
don't say anything i just kiss her right
he goes no
no no no no you're gonna look or you're
gonna say give me some sugar baby i was
like that's so
[ __ ] because you're gonna do it do it
you do it
cause sam gets pissed if you don't
immediately go wow that's awesome
you know he'll get pissed at you so i
went okay fine we'll say your stupid
line
you know and other things just occur to
you uh
this i got my foot on the neck of a
creature in evil dead too and it keeps
going
i'll swallow yourself smile your soul so
ash is about to blow it away
so we just go swallow this
you know so they would come out and it
was a type of character that
by the time sam did army darkness ash
was a full-on
ugly american trash talker how he
evolved into that
is really mostly sam because he's you
know the first evil dead he's a generic
milk toast 21 year old guy who
happens to be more of a survivor than
anything and evil that too he's kind of
like a vietnam vet
right he's a little wary and then by my
army of darkness he's just
he's a smart ass which is i love it i
mean
i don't like milk toast lead characters
that's the problem with lead characters
they write the bad guy you played a
great bad guy right did they not write
great stuff for you yeah you could be an
[ __ ] and chew the scenery
look at me here's my bad guy speech
before i take you down the bad guys get
written
really well and they make the mistake of
underwriting the good guys